each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
we're very happy to have shin lee from
University of Washington with us today
shin got his PhD working with the
professor david zuckerman at UT austin
and is now a summons postdoctoral fellow
at the University of Washington it's
done a lot of very nice work and the
area of randomness extractors and its
application to cryptography and he's
going to be talking to us about privacy
amplification and non malleable
extractors thanks love thank you ok so
this is a joint work with your gun in
tullys October bully and Debbie document
the title is privacy amplification and
nonmetal extract us by our character it
sums ok so let me start with the
introduction of these problem so first
this setting is that you have to part of
you status and Bob standin and so they
share some random string but the random
string is not uniform instead is just
some weekly random strings which I'm
going to define our formula later and to
notice that these stringy secrets in a
sense that it is not done to the
anniversary you so they were sorry who
is used watching this channel and we
also assume that these two parties have
local random bits which are probably
innocence that the local revenues are
zone not known to the other bursary so
what is this problem the problem is
basically are that two parties in the
presence of the service rep they want to
somehow communicate with each other
mm-hmm such that at the end of the
protocol they want to agree on their
share the uniform and probably random
strings so these two strings are there
going to be the same for both parties
and they are supposed to be uniform and
private in the sense that the districts
are still not known to deliver sleep so
that's a basic setting
and it is talking also you now work with
assuming that you visa computationally
unbounded so you view visa computational
body then we can somehow use the
standard crib topic are primitives deal
with this problem but we are not
assuming that instead of assuming that
you've has a man limited computational
power so this framework is basically
purely information Syracuse setting all
right so it's just said assuming that
the two parties share a weekly random
string and the formal male formal model
for some weak random string is called
the week random sauce so basically if
you have an MBA string then the week
random sauce is just some random
variable or a destroyer probabilities
distribution over the empty streets but
then you need a way to mayor the entropy
of the weak sauce which we were going to
married by the non-standard notion of
being entropy so it is simple that if
source has miniature bikini then
basically it's saying that for any
el-medina support the property that the
random ever takes this support is at
most 2 to the minus K and for this talk
and also for open most of the
applications using week random sources
you can just simply sync up the wii
cream sauce to be some uniform
distribution over some large subsets
which has size that leads to the K so
yep so that that's that's going to make
our nannies is simple so just assume
that the sauce is a week you are use a
uniform distribution over these subset a
sorry can you always go from peaceful
school yeah the the thing is that every
week sauce with me on to BK is actually
a convex combination of the flower
sources okay so uh okay so as the title
suggests I'm going to talk about
randomness extractors and so buddy is a
random is extractor so basically it's
supposed to be some algorithm that that
is given as they impose some weak random
string weak sauce I'm base with some
entropy k and the algorithm is supposed
to output say mb's that is supposed to
be uniform by the way allow we allow the
outpost we have some small statistically
error and the error is just the our one
no more the statistical error or the
variation distance but the problem is
that if you want the extractor to be a
deterministic algorithm then this task
is actually impossible even if the big
random source has ench be something like
n minus 1 and even you could just want
out to one bit that is impossible if you
want the extractor to be a deterministic
a person so then given the negative
result so there are several different
ways to attack this problem and one of
these is what we now call a seeded
extractor which is introduced by the
paper in the paper by knitting and zakah
me and then subsequently studied in many
research papers so here now the
extractor is not a deterministic
algorithm studied is a probabilistic
algorithm in the sense that TT is also
given a small random seat which will
call why that has dp's the city is going
to be independent of the week ranch
sauce
and then with the seat you can output
munity you can outputs some mps with
most statistical area and the go here
you said that you want this number bsd
to be much smaller than the lens of the
seed so generally we would want this d
to be something like all the login if
this absolutely some constant so this
kind of object City extract has been
studied a lot and now we have nearly
optimal constructions of these kind of
extractors and we were also going to
need the noshing of a strong extractor
so basically this is saying that not
only is the output distribute
distributing close the uniform but it is
also close to uniform even if you're
given the seed why here so basically
just saying the joint distribution of
the output and the white these are close
to a uniform distribution okay so so
given that previously a strong extractor
here use is a protocol for the privacy
amplification problem where the
anniversary is assumed to be passive so
bypass Eva I mean that the adversary is
only allowed to watch the messages
transmitted between the two parties but
she is not allowed to change the
messages in anyways so in this setting
our there's a simple protocol using
strong our city extractors so the
protocol is that first you have a DS
pick some uniform random seed y from her
own local we are local random bits then
I just just send this string to pop and
then the just apply this strong City
extractor you know this they both supply
this stones and extractor and the claim
is that they're going to end up with
some share dutiful and
private random string and why is this
the case this is big images because that
the adversary can now change the sea so
both Alice and Bob get the same seat why
and now they apply the extra extractor
and because it is strong which means
that even if your condition as seed why
the output is close to utica and also
because here the only information that
you can get you see is a seed why here
so even condition on this the output is
cross beautiful which means that
basically they're probably to the
University so that is that is a simple
protocol but if you think about it if
now we allow the ER vessel to be active
in the sense that you can indeed change
the messages then the above protocol
actually fails it fails for a simple
reason because the adversity can change
these random string Y into something
else by Prime and then if you apply this
strong extractor again then these two
outputs they may no longer be equal to
each other so in this case the protocol
fails
right so now more specifically what do
we mean by an activity for three so it
is a very powerful anniversary in a
sense that the river Surrey can somehow
arbitrary chain insert delete modify and
reordered messages and for example the
bursary can first run several rounds
with one party before it's decides to
resume execution with the other part
meaning that it is sense the protocol
may not be behave synchronously between
the two parties so so so here you need
these activities race is a very quite
powerful adversary and I need is talk as
well you know work we are assuming that
adversary is active so we're trying to
deal with this kind of a top story okay
so here is an a formal definition of a
prophecy amplification protocol so so
here we are assuming that we have an
adverse active adversary and so in the
end the two parties Addison Bob they are
supposed to output some strings but they
can also i'll put some special symbol
here so this symbol just indicates that
this party will rejects a protocol and
way for the prophecy amplification
protocol we will require the protocol to
have three properties so the first is
that is called correct this so this is
simple this just said that you ve if
you've adversary is passive then who is
probably one the the two outputs of the
two parties are the same and they are
not equal to the rejection symbol here
this is actually quite intuitive and
then I robustus a robustness which says
if he is indeed active then the property
that you can crop the protocol is small
so what I mean by you
to the protocol so you can crop the
protocol you've imagined humanity she
managed to somehow make the two outputs
are a and not B not equal to each other
and also the another rejection symbol in
this case we would say that the you've
actually I corrupts the protocol and we
want to one that the probability that
you can do this is small and then the
third property is just the extraction
property which says if we skype probably
a a party does not reject then he saw
her output is going to be close to
uniform even in the adversary's view so
that's a that's actually the go of the
the original go of the protocol to get
to convert the original week random
sauce into a uniform screen okay and now
we have the two parameters that are
particularly interesting here so first
of all these k minus M so M is the
length of the outputs k use the entropy
of the original week random sauce so k
minus M is the entropy loss of the
protocol and we also have this parameter
epsilon here and we're defying s which
is like one or absolute to be the
security parameter of the protocol sure
what does it
you
if one of them yeah if one of them gets
are you from string and then the other
guests bottom and that is okay because
the update body actually rejects the
protocol one person always knows the
other person fails
maybe not getting around
yeah you may not be this case right with
blocked and Ozma right
hey just knows so a dystopia
besharam
one we like your kisses that's right
yeah right yeah that's right thank you
okay so any other questions I is it
clear about the definition here okay
right
okay so so now this table shows some of
the previous works here so remember
remember ask here is the security
parameter so basically the the ultimate
goal of the privacy amplification
protocol is that you want to get a
protocol with a small number a small
number of rounds as possible and you
want to get a small entropy loss as
possible so of course the here the first
result due 2morrow animove in nineteen
seven I guess one run protocol which is
pretty good but the only work for
entropy read it actually is something
like k is greater than two-thirds of in
and then should be lost is pretty big is
something like I'm minus K and then this
protocol is later improved by these
authors dou by dou decent case raising
and des amis I guess to work for the
case where and should be ready entropy
is greater than and over to potential
allows you stupid is one wrong here and
just just note to note that there is a
negative results by now toadies and
weeks in in this paper which basically
shows that if this entropy k is smaller
than n over 2 then there is no why run
pretty good so in that case the best you
can get is to run protocols okay but by
the first protocol that breaks this end
over to Barry is due to Renee Renee on
the roof in 2003 so they actually give a
protocol which can essentially work for
any entry here but it would require
something wrong something like this s
plus log in and then should be lost you
saw CS plus log and squared and and then
then there is also a slightly
simplification and abided by this paper
of canoga the--and raising
but the parameters I essentially say and
then there is this paper without recent
weeks who reduced the round of the
rottens number runs 22 by the HP loss is
2 s plus log in squared and then there
is this paper by a check out to here and
also for so this for authors who are who
managed to get entry lost to something I
guess plus log in but then the number of
rounds blows up to also something like s
plus log in and just just note that the
optimal protocol who is a pro body in
this paper by thousand weeks but the but
is now explicit so they show that now
explicitly you have this optimal
protocol which can achieve two rounds
and you have optimized velasquez + log
in so all of the previous results they
can just only achieve optimum I mean
just one of these two parameters you can
ship the two rounds but then the HP loss
is bigger well or you can ship the
optimized we lost but then the rum is
bigger s plus log in so the oven problem
is is that if we can achieve optimum in
both of these parameters and and in this
paper but notice and weeks they show
that this optimal results can actually
be achieved by using something called a
nonmetal extractor so which I'm going to
talk about later so these these are the
previous results okay
so what are our results are basically in
this paper we give to improvements of
the previous results so in the case
where the entropy is bigger than our
number two so you get we get a two-run
protocol up so recall that indeed you
you have one run protocol by the HP loss
has to be much bigger n minus K so here
we get it to run protocols but we get
optimum entropy loss as plus log in and
then in this case where you only have
like say any constancy so here the
ptertha is any arbitrary constant so in
this case if you have any data and
entropy here then we actually get a
protocol that is pretty close to the
optimal result we get a constant number
run protocol that also has entropy loss
as plus well optimized we lost s plus
log in here if this constant depends on
on this dirt idea so there's as long as
Delta is constant this is also
counseling ok so we we obtain these two
improvements by constructing the first
explicit now value extractors so in the
rest of the talk i'm going to press talk
about the number of extractors
construction and say a few words about
the proof and then i will talk about the
prophets implication protocol floor with
you for this entropy rates dirt and
where that is any constant i'm also
going to sell few words about this to
rob protocol which which is actually a
direct corollary from the result of
doggies and weeks right so now what is a
number of extractor defining so it is
defining this paper by tourists weeks so
our first to start with a city extractor
as you have seen before so this is
simple you just have an extractor you
have a seat in output and they are
outputting super
to be close to uniform so here this
notion just means that the output has
ever a statistical error epsilon from
the uniform distribution and then so
this is a city extractor so a stronger
notion of the city's factor which you
have also seen before you the strong
City extractor which requires that even
if you are you also give you the seed
why here the outputs is still close to
you from so now the number by extract in
a way you can just think of it as a even
stronger notion of the strong City
extractor so here you are you're not on
oh you're not only given you seed why
but you're also given an output of the
number of extractor on some coral it is
seed a why here so they say why is
assumed to be not equal to the original
seed why but except from the ec say why
could be a virtually correlated to the
seed why so now we require that even if
you are given a seed why and also you
are given the outputs of the number of
extractor a virtually correlated a why
the original outputs of the extractor
you still close to uniform since and
just as a note that the output cannot be
bigger than the entropy over to here
okay so is a use this definition clear
any problems
if something permission is already named
above my person p yeah actually the seed
why is completely leaked to the
anniversary
pokemon violence to chosen
oh yeah why was to choosing uniform
before and the reverse we can also
choose another see a whi which is not
equal to Y but accept this condition you
can choose whatever it wants they say
one could be arbitrarily correlated to
this seed why and then the adversary
also gets the information of the of the
number of extractors output on this CJ
why here which means that she actually
now gets to kind of emissions it gets
this seed ye gets these outputs on
another seat a way and we're requiring
that even if the ovary gets these two
informations still the the output of the
number of extractor and the original
seed why is close to your phone you're
saying that it's just like strands of
extractor but now even if you can
challenge for them cities to
from the from using extract select the
purpose of her head and he cannot
right yeah so it's actually much
stronger than the strong said extractor
in the sense that the elbow surg gets
another output here another case you're
looking for
come on
I'm sorry can say that again so think of
this one IBM right yeah where the
adversary is supposed to output I string
pulls output looks correlated to log
from extracting yeah that's right and he
can do that because in the second
experiment is uniform so they will never
become as in experiment on the left is
the actual extractor so in the
statistical across
Yeah right not even just output
economist
opening much stronger
it's mean it's not much bigger
requirement for the area for yourself
here's stronger none if you were
normally would be than you need a
statistic it's a committee with are
there is drastically they could have
been congressional
right but here here we are where we are
considering the information to work
setting so because they're in the
statistical distance okay any other
questions okay okay so just to give you
some sense of the anomaly extractor
here's a negative example so if we
consider this extractor which is just
the inner product so you take a source X
you take a independent seed why so here
this why has the same lens at the source
and you just take the inner product of
the few adapt to this is actually a very
strong a very good strong extractor so
it actually works for me essentially any
me entropy here but it turns out is a
very bad not my way extractor so it is
it is not an admirable extractor even
even if the entropy kk is is something
like n minus 1 so to see these you can
consider this source x our wish as the
first speed fixed to be 0 and the rest
of the base adjust a uniformly
distributed so so you can see that this
sauce has entropy m minus 1 now these
adversary giving any seed why he can
just make this a wide 2 br2 to be the
string that has the first piece of x
flipped and the rest of the piece are
the same and then you can see usually
that X in the product with why is always
the same as X you know product with a
here so wish me is that these this
extract this party is a very good strong
instructor it is a very bad normal if
extracted here so which somehow suggest
that the task to construct a number of
extractor is not a trivial thing
okay so in this paper by August weeks
they showed that if you can construct
non-model big structures for hbk then
you can actually give the optimal
protocol a prophecy amplification
protocols for essentially the same thing
entropy and the managed to show that
such kind of normal extractors exist so
we're so if you think about it he's not
even clear that these kind of things
exist but they show that this kind of
things actually indeed exist and they
show that you can use the seedlings the
something similar in a city extracted
something else must login here and then
you can extract up to something like em
r equals to K over 2 if you just ignore
the others thing you can extract up to K
over 2 bits but they they didn't give
any constructions that the explicit
normal effects practice they only
construct some weaker forms of not met
with records but i'm not going to
describe this ok so i'll so in this
paper we give the first explicit in that
multi extract before our work there is a
no known explicit constructing some
normal exit you extractable whatever
power it is so so this number of extract
we construct works for HP ready n to be
greater than n over 2 and it uses
seedlings and so the seedlings use the
same at the source and it outputs us
seems like k minus the number two piece
so if this k is SE and over 2 plus theta
and so then in this case we can output a
linear number piece here but uh but if
we if we want output mobis you want for
more than log n bits then the efficiency
about construction relies on some
conjectures about promising array
somatic progressions
but I'm not going to talk talk about get
into the details about this just some
random conjectures so the corollary we
get is to run privacy application
protocol ah if we assume assume these
conjecture this is a direct corollary
salted 13 weeks and then we get we using
this number of extractor even if only
given you feet on your breaks for
entropy great and number two we manage
you to get a new protocol that runs in
constant number of rounds and we get
also optimal entropy laws okay so so
there's a one very nice subsequent work
here which is by cohn reznick yep who
also give a construction that works for
entry great and over to that they can
use a small seed lens indeed you can use
something like log in but their outputs
is actually smaller than the seedlings
which means is that if you want to
output a large number of Eastern
seedlings is use again use force to be
large and also they that construction
does not rely on any other improvements
options so in fact I'll constructing is
can be viewed as special case of their
construction and also up up to sink
their nice paper we we actually show
that our original number of extract
works even if the given impetus city is
not beautiful even you could see the
only has some bhp something like M plus
log and times some constant here these
these again interns that we can also
achieve a small seedlings as in their
construction huh well but this work is
only done after which we have seen their
paper
ok ok so now I'm going to talk a little
bit about our construction of the
nematic extractors so if you want to
output one beats then the construction
is actually is simple is sighs just the
polygraph constructing over some finite
field FQ here so to be more specific so
we like KY as here to be the quadratic
character so if if a flag ok ask us is
some some squares some square up some
elements than this one if not then use
minus one you first equal to 0 then this
is 0 of course you can very conveniently
convert this in plus 1 minus 1 to 0 and
1 and also it's note that this quadratic
character is a multiplicative character
which means that the KS times to use kya
stomach skyteam here an hour our
extractor here is simple we just take a
source X you take an independency boy
and you compute the quadratic character
of X plus y over some cleared fq here
and if you want to output mobis then is
basically the this extractor that has
been started before in this paper like
car and go drink but they study this
extractor in the context of too salty
crackers and we show that is also a
number of extractor so here we're
basically to choose some prime that is
congruent to 1 mod to do them and that G
to be a generating this field FQ so the
conjecture I mentioned before implies
that such a prime Q can be found
efficiently and then the extractor is
just on the disk discrete log of X plus
y what some to do them so am here is the
number of output bits here and it turns
out we can compute this discrete log mod
to do them in a vision way but that also
relies the contingent ah
no well no this doesn't rely on the
conjecture but we need this but the
conjecture is just to find this prime Q
ok so in conjecture on really one thing
you need to put it so even if for
example finding this crime takes time
you need to be literally once yeah
that's not for every application that's
right exactly ok so now I'm going to say
a few words about the analysis so why
this is a number of extractor so
basically basically to show that this is
number of extractors it's supposed to
show that most of the sea is why so
first of all this party is closed
beautiful this is actually already
follows from the party that this thing
is anna is a strong instructor so i'm
not going to go into the details days
but this thing has already been proved
in this old paper by client Godric that
this isn't strong extractor so the main
part we need proof is that the so so he
is 41 Pete's case go and prove that the
XO of these two things are still coast
beautiful that means that these sub put
is somehow uncorrelated with the
original output
yep and and uh yeah just this is this is
essentially to the same thing as but
that one of the show the first party is
close to use moment there that these
acts all with this is closed beautiful
so to prove these are the main tool we
use this is a character some estimate so
this is is a little messy here but the
main thing is that so this s are you can
think of is the support of the week
random sauce which is the subset and so
the weak rand sauce you can think of it
just as the uniform distribution over
this set s and they say it's just the
university function from fq t fq so when
you have wide advisory changes to
something some a why here so basically
to show that
this is basically to show this thing is
the place is to show that these these
potholes so this is basically saying
that for the sum the overall see is why
that so you know the xor when you
convert it into the quadratic character
it's basically you see equivalent to the
multiplication here so basically you
want to show this and the main tool to
prove this is why roseum so basically it
says if F is a monic polynomial overs
let's say with our distinct reduce and
that is not as squares then the the
absolute value of this summer the
quadratic character of FG whether these
over the whole field FQ is eastbound is
bounded away from k so the the tribute
band is something like Q here but here
the bong gets much small like something
like you to a square root of Q here so
using these we could bound this quantity
here
so i guess i'm not going to go into the
details but just let me skip these
so let me just say that in the other
weekend we can end up with estimating
some company like this and here these
this H is is basically a product I use
the parlor mooing s with the grid for
and so you can you can you can check
that these edges are square if and only
if y equals to Z or y equals y z and z
equal story why and then you can just
divide you the two cases and you can
bound this thing tripoli by considering
the suitcases whether use a square or
it's not and you get this bone here and
just just note that if we want to
analyze the case where you extract more
bits then you need to estimate this
thing for any non-trivial characters chi
and chi prime and to do that we need
some kind of non-uniform XO lamers okay
okay so uh so the rest of the talk i'm
going to describe this prophecy
application protocols for NTV right k
equal to 10 for any constant data here
so to describe the protocol was going to
introduce some cryptography primitive
called the message authentication code
or you can just simply sign some mac so
what is a message authentication code so
again here you have to party you said
listen Bob here but here we assume that
instead of sharing some weekly random
string their shares share some beautiful
private string are here and also they
have a again they have these setups or
at you who is active with
computationally unbounded and who can
choose this channel between the two
parties so what what does this back to
so essentially so here at is Peaks a
uniform random string Y so this string Y
is from is chosen from her own local we
create a local uniform random bits and
that is sends the string Y together with
some tag tu here this is tech t is
computed from this Mac by using this
share the random random bits are as a
seat so this will be the back uses a
random seed are here to compute it to
computer tag tea for this message bike
here in this case at askance NY and the
tag to Bob but as usual the adversary
you can change the messages into
something else can try to change it to
into some y prime on T Prime and the
main property that the message
authentication code we wanting is that
if the adversary you does not know the
shared shared eurocom string are then
the probability that the adversary can
come back come up with a different
string Y Prime and can also come up with
a cracked tag t prime for this message y
prime is going to be more complete body
bias and
epson here so that's a line properties
that we need for message authentication
code so easy this clear any questions
fine okay and just to note that so this
back works in the in this case where
this art is beautiful random we just
know that there are constructions of the
message has been cashing codes which
works even if these are is not
completely uniform random but if this
are has HP rates greater than a half
then it still works so n should be an
interview right here just means there
should be divided by the length of the
string are here so we have this kind of
Max ever XD when you fire is not
completely beautiful
okay so given the previous message
authentication code so here's a protocol
for the case where the HOV rate is
entropy rate is greater than hut so this
is basically the protocol by doggies and
weeks plus the construction of our
normal but extractor here so now these
two parties in sebab they share some NK
with random so so so this just means
that the source is lens in and a des
entropy kk again the first step is at is
chosen chooses a random string Y from
the local random bits and it sends it to
Bob and this could be changed by the
rest r into something else y prime here
and then both parties using this number
by extracted to compute outputs so that
is confused that the number of external
extract applied to X and Y Bob computes
the number of extraocular applies to x
and y prime so they now get two outputs
r and r prime here which may not equal
to each other and then in the next round
Bob would choose some double prime so
this is a uniform random string from his
own local random bits and then Bob will
send the blue prom together with the
tag-team prime that is this tech is
computed by using this output r prime as
a Mac key to to get attack from for his
message double prime it sent it to Ellis
and of course thatís would may get
something completely different you may
get some WT here and then and then Alice
will just check the back we check that
if this tech is the correctly Mac for
this message w she receives and if not
then other switches to reject otherwise
you palace does not reject then she will
compute these outputs and Bob we always
compute these young outputs Z prime K
so so I claim that this is a prophecy
amplification protocol and the dynasty's
turns out to be simple just a you
consider two cases the first case is
that the reverse area Eve does not
change the seat why if the adversary
does not change Y than Y prime and y are
basically the same which means that our
primer or are and are also the same and
also since this number will be extracted
is also strong City extractor this our
prime and are at the same and they are
privates in use view and then as I just
said by the property of the Mack the pub
can authenticate his message double
prime to eddies and it was three if he
wants to change it to some w WT then
probably that Alice does not reject it's
going to be smoked by the property of
the Mack yeah on the other hand if the
adversary does change Y so if the
observer a change is pointing to
something are different Y prime then the
number we extract the public guarantees
that these are prime is actually a this
is our problem is actually independent
of are soaked and even condition I
promise our is beautiful so then so then
even if the Earl of Surrey if he see you
she sees this Mac T prime because this
only comes from this output our prime
which is completely independent of our
so you can give this the information the
advisory cannot come up with a cracked
egg will for this this message WK which
means in this case that is we also
reject with high probability so so
basically two cases you doesn't change Y
than the magic guarantees that Bob can
also indicate the message to eddie's if
if it does change wire then the number
of X Factor are probably guarantees that
dalits we reject
high priority in this protocol is this
protocol clear okay so and then by
plugging our number of extractor plan to
be read greater than half we get this to
run protocol and just know that um at
all of these messages why are these W&T
prom has has learned something like as
plus log in so you get the optimal
entropy loss protocol yeah so the answer
is just like set is whether you've
changes is seat why here okay so so then
I'm going to describe this privacy
application protocol for the case where
a case is equal to Delta n so you
basically use these previous protocols
so again here you have a despot you
venue they share a week random source
key so the first study I used at so we
want to apply this number we extracted
for entropy right great and a half but
here this source only has a very small
HP raider thank you so the first thing
either use that we can apply a sum
something called a somewhere a condenser
so what is the somewhere condenser so
basically it's a deterministic a girl
that can convert these quick random
sauce with the entropy Delta into a
number of constant number of blocks so
this constant number or the wonky it
depends on this dirty thank you but
namely is constant number of blocks such
that at least one of the blockheads
entropy raised a great system than point
nine here and then so you can see is so
it's very natural that you can convert
into this and then you want to somehow
try the previous protocols in some of
these blocks where the entropy rate is
greater than half
so so so indeed the idea is that you
want to apply this to run protocol to
every block here and then we hope that
at some of the intermediate block where
there should be ready is bigger than up
the protocol will succeed okay so most
specifically we're going to associate
the face of the protocol with each of
the block and we want a final protocol
to achieve the following two goes the
first go is that in the face the face of
the first good block so by the first
good block I mean the first block that
has actually write great and a half so
so even the use East grout then this
block is bad and then this block is good
then this is a first go to block so you
want to say that in the first good block
are so Addison Bob we agree on private
uniform random string so this in this is
in this place associate with this first
good block so at the end of the first
the end of this phase are the two
parties share agreed on some private
uniform random string in the second goal
we want to achieve is that what's this
is done then way somehow want to
guarantee that in all subsequent phases
are they continue to agree on some
private beautiful random string and then
if this use case are then we can just
use the output from the the last phase
and the final output because here they
agree on a uniform runs doing and then
they continue to agree on a uniform
rammstein then so at the end they still
agree on some uniform random strings
okay so let's see how we can achieve
Frisco here so of course of course if
you if you think about it then the
further the first goal is to achieve to
have the two parties agree on a uniform
random string at the first good block
the first good block already has entropy
right great and a half but the message
is sent before the first good phase may
leak some information about the food
first good luck so inviting us have been
should be right correct and a half but
the solution is that we can limit the
size of the messages send before the
first good block so as long as the
security department is not too large we
can leave me the size of the messages so
that because you notice that there's
only a constant number of blocks though
there is at most a constant number of
rounds so you can leave me the size of
the messages messages such that because
the size of the match is small so the
information leaks is small so you can
County even if you condition that all
the messages sent before the good block
still has entropy right great and a half
and so in this case we are we did and
then plugging the previous to run
protocol for it should be right career
and a half we guarantee that we achieve
the first girl that ad in the end of
their first the face of the first good
block the two parties will agree on some
uniform random string that are private
to the other bursary okay let's see how
we can ship go to here so okay so here
is a is a this graph shows a particular
face so the first is for the block X I
here so this shows something up to the
first after the face of the first good
block so here these excise I say int
repeatedly red greater there are less
and up so as picture shoes
so this is exactly the same protocol the
same to run / codes before I didn't I
didn't change anything I just change the
just added this subscript I hear all the
ex-wives become X i advertised ok so
this in the face i hear so first status
shows this why I and a sin to Bob and so
the reverse or email chain you to why I
Prime and it computes sorry I and are a
prime and then Bob chooses wi prime and
sunday 2 powers together with the tak TI
prime computed using are a prime and
Ennis checks you've this mac TI if Mac
TI she receives is correct if not then
she rejects otherwise i compute the
output zi which is some extract apply to
x and wi n wi prime so this is the
exactly the same to run protocol as
before but if you think about then then
the political may fail because here the
X i we have small entropy small entropy
so then should be rain might be smaller
than half so the previous to run
protocol may not work basically these
the back ways ok are I'm a film so what
are we going to do this solution is that
also remembering the when when we first
reached the face of the first book up
good block we already have at the end of
the database we already have the two
parties agree on some uniform rena
string so we can use that shared uniform
random string from previous row to
construct another mac so this CI plan
minus one is the output string from the
previous ROM so we just need to
construct another mac
and then we will also use this back to
authenticate a message w prime here
instead of using just one Mac we use use
using just one Mac we will use another
mac to authenticate this message double
Prime so this seems to be good except we
have another problem which is that the
back of the constructor using this I
here may leak information about these
are string zi minus one but the solution
is that as we have saying that there are
max that are resilient even you've risen
to leakage even if the reversing knows
some information about the mac is er
minus one as long as the leakage is not
too much as long as this CL minus one
still has entry right greater than the
hub then this back hands do work because
these are a leakage resident mac ok so
here this is a modified protocol here so
again this is same to run protocols I
didn't change anything ok so now I'm
going to add another thing that they
have the output from the previous phase
they are most one here so so this is uh
this is a this is a run-up to the rock
this is a face up at the first the face
of the first good block say so the two
parties already shared some uniform
random probably random output from
previous runs the I minus 1 here and
then instead of just using this Mac to
authenticate w i prime we use another
Mac sugar coke UI prime which is which
is this Mac this air our mac which
stands for the leakage resonant Mac so
we use this di Prime the r minus 1 prime
is a key for this leakage resident Mac
to authenticate a poop I Prime
another tack UI prime so we send both of
these texts to eddies and of course
ladders can get some modified version
wtq and then others instead of just
checking one back and chest check posts
you will check both of this max and she
will reject you if either one of these
does not hold otherwise they were just
compute the output di as before so now
if you think of it then I it's very nice
so in the at the end of the protocol
protocol at the end of the face for the
first first good block the two parties
end up with some beautiful random string
and then this will guarantee that in a
sub subsequent round they will also end
up with their agree on some given from
random string and then in the next round
they can use this say I then they will
again end up with some great uniform
random string and this keeps going on
until the last day until the last phase
yeah sure
yes
yeah even if the key is not uniform but
has entropy great great and up Yeah Yeah
Yeah right so basically the only thing
that I viscera can know about this di
prime as they r minus 1 promise I these
TI prime Seng because these these why's
this WC at the house they are all
independent of this thing so we can so
we're going to set this attack say the
size of tag to be smaller at the half of
the e the length of the imax 1 then this
leakage resin in back will guarantee
that a pop can also indicate this step
we are primed to Alice okay so okay so
we're almost done however there is a one
little subtle problem here so the
problem is that the youth may not behave
synchronously which means that you can
you can talk to Bob many times between
it talked to Alice so so in this case
I'll so the Addison bump may not have a
synchronous view of the protocol so they
may not use the same Zi order or Zi to
construct a mac which causes a problem
of the protocol so the the solution to
these are that this last problem is that
we can add a lively stands for both
parties at at the end of each phase so
basically if here when Bob sends wi
prime to Alice he will also require a
response from Alice by applying some
extractor a strong extractor 2x and
doubly so but we will check this
response so if this response is not
equal to uh huh his output then he will
reject and when any sense his response
to Bob we will send also her
challenge this is VI and Bob we also
compute the response and send you too
blob and instantly to Addis and as we
also check and if this response doesn't
match then she will reject this is
basically saying that you've if you've
tries to talk to say you've tribes to
talk to just to talk to Bob many times
before she talks to that is then you
will not get a response from Ellis so
should we have to come up with response
are fake a response from matters to to
make Bob go through this cell response
check but then that is that can only
happen can succeed only weighs very
small probably it up because it's a
strong extractors so the response thing
if if does not down X then this thing is
completely healed from the eaves view so
the project that you can come up with
correct response are to block without
the matter with other response from
Alice's can't be very small in that case
but we reject with high probability so
in this case in this case by adding this
nervous test we can make sure that the
protocol actually behaves synchronous as
we want yeah
ok so that is uh sure soon
Chris the ground
like this discomfort is it
before you good luck yeah you need to do
the lava stocks I have a test for every
phase to ensure that they two bodies
behave synchronously yeah you if they
are in different boxes you see another
it W is right
we're not looking bucket we still
put W is WI prom is chosen from Bob some
profits local randomness so so yeah just
by adding these liveliest test into our
previous protocols so that gives our
final protocols and right because you
know in each face there is only like two
rounds something like that so you get a
constant number of rounds because you
have a constant number blocks and
because each of these things they have a
so the size of each of the use message
is something like s plus log in so
there's the final HP last you some eyes
only all the s plus log in okay yep okay
so that is our final protocol and here's
some conclusion blue is an open open
questions so we construct the first
number of extractor per inch we greater
than / in number two so of course the
first open problem is to construct the
number of extractors for small entropy
say dirty and or even into the third
licensing and and just note we recently
get an improvement that can we can
achieve that we can construct the number
of expected for entropy rate slowed
slightly we have you have a be below and
number two it's something like a point
for line and something like that but it
still remains of the construct number of
extractors for any custom interiors are
here oh well into the UN to the point
nine would be very big improvement and
then the second result is that we get a
discount number on the council number
run prophecy application protocol for
the case where a k equals good to 13 and
you'll be interesting to get get the
number of runs down to two runs in that
case we will get the truly optimal
pretty cool and and and then again even
if we can get a constant up around the
protocol for the case where I k you
could equal to n 2 Delta so even to that
point nine that we very big improvements
previous results and Nestle thank you is
it easy to construct the there some way
to construct an online extractor up in
many bits from a non-married extractor
of one bit by increasing the same deal
right so that is actually a related to
another so we had we have another
improvement actually here so as I said
right so here so so this this result by
Cohan residents to get they are they
have the the output is smaller than
seedlings so we have another improvement
that we can somehow by giving these kind
of a nominal extracted out and outputs
just one number of this we can use some
other kind of tools to get it to output
a large number bits yeah but but there's
that's do only that still needs that
these output to be at least log in yeah
so if you if you want to use a number of
X right that output just one bit to
convert into an emblem extra that I'll
promote this then that is to open we
don't know how to do that
and also what happens if you so you have
this protocol for entropy Lafayette have
achieved by splitting up the constant
number of blocks right if you build up
to super constant number of blocks you
probably would not get better those
understand the existing ones would you
can submit that
alright so see so actually our
particular we have this constant number
around protocols for K equals dead end
but you can we can actually get
something slightly sublinear but then we
wouldn't get a constant that where else
we would get and the entropy loss is not
optimal but it can still be better than
s plus log n squared but there's only
very slightly sublinear if you go beyond
a certain point then the number of runs
would blow up to pour la me or something
otherwise otherwise otherwise